hello today we're going to be having a
look at the theocratic class as
represented here today by nomeland Fitz
megistus a goblin in the clouds you see
him here in this capital city of ramus
in the little blighted mushroom swamps
and over here to the right we see our
foe
larysa mirabilis a sorcerer a witch no
less I'm going to break into our city
and burn her at the stake the heresy
now this is a scenario that we've set up
so that you can sort of see what the end
game will look like and right let's have
a look at what's kinds of spells we can
cast now as a theocratic themed we can
mark people as heretics we can summon
cherubs little flying demon baby
monsters you have a beacon of faith set
up in our city so that grows faster paid
absolution you can force the citizens to
pay us for the privilege of being a
members of our religion stuff like that
let's start off let's mark Larissa as a
heretic or it's a good place to start so
that means that we'll be able to do more
damage to her units now we're gonna be
mostly focusing on a battle today I'm
gonna bring my army over here and engage
now you ever thing called you Jason hex
rules so not only is the stack we are
attacking engage in battle but all of
the surrounding stacks are going to be
engaged as well so you can see that it's
actually going to be our 12 units versus
hurt in there could be up to 42 units in
a battle if every single hex is filled
so let's enter battle and see what
happens
here we are nom lick Trismegistus
attacked Larissa memorably I don't know
who came up with these names anyway so
she's a defender so she gets to go first
see what she does we were all starting
out for a side not much you could you
see she's gonna cost haste on this
cellar over here now this is oh it's my
turn okay sorry about that
okay this is an eldritch horror this is
the most powerful unit to the sorcerer
can summon and it's an
nightmare it is a heretic since mark is
a heretic we just cost but it also has
haste meaning it can move twice as far
as shock breast so it's essentially a
dragon breath open attack but with
lightning it does spirit damage and
blight damage and worst of all it's
immune to both blight damage and spirit
damage which is a problem since goblins
do blight damage and theocrats do spirit
damage but we'll we'll sort of have some
how she's also got some apprentices here
they are the normal sorcerer unit of
those who lick little mini wizards you
can fairy fire for a lightning bolts at
us from their walls he disciplined
dispel magic he also got some archers
and these guys phantasm warriors they're
a middle-level source or a summon
they're very tough do a fairly nice
amount of damage they have the chance to
shock the target so that when they hit
people their target is stunned and
doesn't move as fast okay now what are
we going to do what have we got okay we
have these guys goblin Crusaders
there's our best look at of hiding
behind their little shield these are
tier two infantry then we have these
guys flying goblins the exalted at tier
three they can sweep over the walls and
hopefully get into the enemy's face
before the arrows can do too much damage
to us we've also got martyrs
Mars's are a low tier unit whose main
gimmick is this ability absorb pain
which I'm actually going to use on these
swarm darters what that means is there's
somebody tries to damage the swamp
diocese and someone that's going to dry
damaged this wound artists then the
damage will actually be transferred to
the martyrs instead so hopefully that
will give these swarmed artists a chance
to actually shoot a bit before they get
torn to pieces by the defenders we've
also got this bad boy over here the
shrine of smiting this is the tier force
theocratic unit it's basically a great
big box of pain has this ability smiting
prayer bolts which does more damage
depending on a more devout units we have
on the field since we have a lot of
hopefully it'll hit pretty hard it also
has divine vengeance a huge AoE that we
can use once per battle now first thing
first let's do some magic now the spell
here holy war
poor old tremor tremor justice fortas
name nom liqu he isn't on the field so
that means this spell is much more
expensive than it you'd usually be but
we're gonna cast it anywhere holy walk
it's +10 damage to all them elite acts
of our unit so hopefully that'll really
do a spit in the ditch there it goes
things all sort of glowing in golden the
glowing glowing glow of impending doom
so Larissa
all right let's advance these guys are
going to stand here hide behind here I
don't think we can get into attack range
at so to wait for next turn
these guys are martyrs let's bring them
over be nice as we could use them to
protect these exalted guards so sliders
goes over here now you want to speed
things up you can right-click it makes
the current action run a bit faster use
absorb pain on them to hopefully they'll
last a bit longer as well our catapult
can fun begin to work on the front door
knock it down catapults are very tough
like all war machines they have resists
resilience which means they take less
damage from projectiles so hopefully
it'll be relatively safe that there we
have our evangelists evangelists are
fear craft support units among the
tricks a can do is healing and touch of
faith touch of faith boosts of the
unit's resistance which makes it take
less damage from elemental attack so
once again we'll cast it on these guys
let's have a feeling the AI has got a
front pick on them who else if we got
the exalted okay waiting in there for
now more exalted now these guys are
flying so they can just fly over the
walls I've been hide here and hopefully
sweep over the walls without taking too
much arrow fire
gobbling Crusaders over here we've got
another take another camera view so we
can actually see you Marta here he's
gonna use it absorb pain on these
Crusaders now Crusaders are infantry
what that means is they have little
ladders so they can scale the walls
they're very vulnerable when they're
doing so but hopefully some of them will
survive enough to actually get off an
attack goes forward
we've moved everyone that we want to
move that right yep okay over to you
Larissa
do your worst Chain Lightning ouch
Oh mate you going oh you just shooting
at my trebuchet didn't do very much and
they're taking potshots at my priests
okay that's both yeah that's one way of
absorbing pain is to stand next to the
unit and get shot instead of the unit
not quite how I intended it but listen
learn doesn't look like my trebuchet is
gonna last much longer either
all Crusaders fortunately they are
protected by the martyrs now hopefully I
will have just as much time to have
knock the wall down before my trebuchet
gets taunt a bit oh not quite yeah well
we'll have to hope for the best man this
guy's gonna fly over here so next turn
he'll be able to get across swarm
dieters are finally in attack range I
believe and we shoot now yes now swarm
dart has actually fire little tiny
mosquitos so they home in them if
they've got no range penalty and no
line-of-sight penalty for shooting over
the walls you can see that it requires
hefty amount of damage and hopefully
they'll survive next time to do some
more damage again in fact since I have a
feeling let's cast this spell instant
Roth means anyone attacking the swarmed
artists well actually take some of the
damage reflected back onto them so
hopefully it'll help them and these
punish people who try and pick on my
poor defenseless little mosquito
shooting friends right these guys are
going to run forwards over here try and
climb up onto those walls when you come
up onto here keep coming on to that
little ladders ready fracture and
unfortunately now because I stood on the
walls their defense has been reduced
quite heavily
which yeah is a bit of a problem but
that's the risk you take if you try and
climb up onto the wall of an enemy
health castle these guys are gonna fly
right over here you're getting ready to
to attack and these guys we we already
marching already martyred you guys can
just hide at the back and probably gonna
die anyway because it was you're paying
YouTube and this can we get into range
do anything for fun right
I mean shooting range I don't think this
is our big area of effect attack but
we're not quite in range yet make it hit
the horror looks like we'd also blow up
our own TV show and we don't really want
to do that we do have these smiting
prayer box so you hit anyone with those
let's kill these archers and the
evangelists for guys priest healer heal
thyself
and the martyrs okay you guys fly over
and come in to stop picking on me okay
over to you again they're at Larissa
okay well either tier 1 archers against
tier 3 unit so they're quite tough
hopefully they'll survive a bit so a
shrine is smiting pretty tucking it as
well hopefully won't them or die though
they are pouring a lot of fire into it
maybe I should have customs to rough on
that instead probably should have
oh well yeah the side effect is the AI
does understand things like instant Roth
so it knows the different attacks Dean
swarm dart is it's gonna take damage
itself so it's not so I guess the spell
is kind of working Oh what are you up to
mr. Eldredge hora slowly floating now
normally he wouldn't be able to move
that fast but Louis that did cost haste
on him so yeah he's a quite a mobile
demonic entity from beyond the grave now
these guys are flying over here God and
the trebuchet finally gets to knock the
door down
raah leaving the way open well this is
door made of it's tough isn't it when he
was a little 1 3 oh well time for our
next trick the shrine of smiting has
divine vengeance 10 fire and 20
lightning damage to everyone within
range who's not devout so let's use it
to blast these guys apart
gotcha unfortunately only used once per
battle but you can see it's always very
effective attack swarmed artists and
miraculously is still alive can start
dishing out more pain over here for
these apprentices we're also quite tough
units who say there's Africa climbing up
into the walls what's going on over here
now here we have a bit of a problem the
exalted have blocked off
Crusaders the Crusaders can't get off
the wall because the exalted's are in
the way not very good planning on my
part unfortunately that means these guys
are going to have to take an attack of
opportunity from these phantasm warriors
but I don't really see where oh I do in
flanking now the phantasm Warriors can
only do an attack of opportunity on
these guys if they're facing them if we
run up behind them and make them turn
around I'd be doing well we could just
kill but that works too
anyway we'll fly over here start
bringing hitting these guys I've tried
to be all clever there shows me so I
just kill things this is what we get
anyway okay so the Crusaders can
hopefully finish off these guys nope
yeah phantasm Warriors have the ethereal
ability I believe now incorporeal it's
called give some 60% physical protection
making them very tough to kill so
there's the tanks for in the Sorcerer's
army or our masters doing Mars are kind
of over here so it can kind of run
forwards can hit anyone with a rock
David and Goliath know
these guys might as well try and I'm
bringing some fire support can they do
anything in range to maybe convert the
enemy nope
nothing in range so yeah just block you
got more martyrs more rocks and yep wrap
units I suppose we can cast net route
casting points as well so over to you
Larissa sure she's gonna do whoops there
goes my trebuchet and here comes this
guy it's not gonna be pretty
aha instant rough go did 11 damage back
though and it gets healed by the The
Apprentice the apprentice for the
sorcerer one of his main jobs is to
follow the sorcerers armies around and
use healing abilities with healing
ability only works on the summoned units
but sorcerer armies tend to have a lot
of summoned units so the they tend to
synergize quite well with each other but
yeah we're getting there we're getting
there right now this guy is still a very
big problem we've got a bunch of unit
but the eldritch horror is a terrifying
terrifying beast and really the safest
thing to do is to shoot it with ranged
attacks ranged attacks that we don't
really have um okay first things first
let's kill the apprentices get those out
of our faces all right they're quite
squishy unit so it doesn't take much to
take them down right should we shoot
Larissa
well should we rain fire and could
really can't do much damage maybe we can
sort of brink do a bit more damage to
those apprentices trying to shoot
through the walls never that good an
idea but um yeah so we can attack with
the Crusaders but the Crusaders yeah
I'm gonna be doing much back eldritch
horrors immune to blight damage
thanks least we can fill the apprentices
yep kill the apprentices and what can we
do
tearful units are the most powerful
units in the game these eldritch auras
are certainly living up to their
reputation and yeah this por el crusader
is here to be sacrifice for the cause
don't really see any other option for
the poor guy so I hit him I do 8 to 12
damage he takes me back does tend to
full-teeth [ __ ] and he has the fearsome
ability which means I have to roll a
save otherwise I'll panic and run away
like a little girl
Oh or I'll just die okay anything for a
rock at him we're not even raised to
throw rocks are you enraged to square
off yeah suck Rock David and Goliath ha
to damage and Crusaders he everyone's
moved the rest his last stand is to her
and her eldritch abomination he's
chucking lightning bolts she's because
of the test scenarios she's still obese
unluckiest Apple to you now
oh and Larissa has officially decided
there's no point in staying behind the
walls anymore the AOS decided this
because it leads three alliance that
well I'm entirely behind the walls and
there's no defensive advantage to using
it anymore so she's decided to come out
and play now
goodbye Larissa it's time for your
wicked heretical ways to you to finally
pay the price off you go blast it off
into orbit and then shrine of smiting vs
eldritch horror who will win
I'll give you a clue it's the eldritch
of the shrine of spikings main damages
spirit and unfortunately the algorithm
is immune to that
anything else we can do you just have to
close it down and like in the best
tradition of religious fanatics we are
simply going to have to drown it in the
blood of the righteous warriors and hope
that in the end we win we'll get them in
the end somehow well rocks you have more
rocks who are you no martyr more rocks
flanking attack with rocks Oh actually
quite a heavy hitter if it's not hiding
behind a wall
really it's becoming a day within
collapse moment maybe we should've just
brought martyrs left everyone else
behind just drown the enemy in the sea
of pebbles okay see what this guy can do
oh they got my martyrs well they they
did they at least had had a go before
they got some pretty pets buzzy
electrical electrical spewing demon
monster thing oh and he's put himself in
a spot where I can only Mele attack him
from one place at once oh this guy's way
more hassle move I'll kill him okay how
much damage is he got last he's got 23
hit points trying to smiting smite to
hit this is not pretty
okay I'm not supposed to show you this
but trying to smiting conflate which
means they can float over walls now this
isn't a final animation so I appreciate
I apologize the hell of you this little
flop right blank range die
no govern exalted can't get to him
because he's hiding on top of the walls
and there's nowhere to step I can't hit
him
damn you AI have been outsmarted by my
own AI okay he's sending you to cover
for me I think we're gonna get him we're
gonna get him yes lone Crusader stabs
him take them down and that
the end of Larisa Robles